let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
and love
that girl died but then she came back
[Music]
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
[Music]
he just hated things the way they are
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
[Applause]
foreign
until we found each other
[Music]
are you ready
for One Last Ride
[Applause]
I'll fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
beautiful sky
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it out what
I noticed how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
foreign